the thing is the thing is there is
someone who works on our team
and uh they are a a big margot
robbie fan and they i would i say
they're willing to do this i mean
they're very keen
uh he's washed his feet talked them
so would is it i mean is it difficult to
do this
tomoji thing no it'll be fine yeah so
adam your moment is here this is
happening
okay okay
so sit down beside uh while we're there
hey i i don't need to criticize my own
production team but you could have taken
your shoes and socks off first
it would have saved a little time you
knew this moment was coming i wanted
more real okay okay here we go here we
go you don't have to do this if you
don't want it no honestly i kept saying
that he wants to do this
okay are you sure yeah okay
oh my god is this oh i know there's
something i have to say now this is
legally uh
don't try this at home
really don't i'll sit on this side of
you okay perfect okay here we go okay
okay in your own time that will it's not
that easy to do
no no okay here we go i actually haven't
done one for a while
i'm sorry i'm probably more nervous than
you are to be honest sorry that's not
comforting i'm not gonna say
my hands are shaking but you don't hear
that
[Applause]
okay sorry
don't worry about your finest work
you do seem happy in your work i really
do
i'm not particularly good but i like
doing it
[Applause]
who's poker face adam very good
sorry is that all right it's good yeah
okay
i can neaten it up like when we're off
like backstage
we really worried for you because he got
on that unicycle look at the size of
that good
good can you see see next time it's a
huge one do you know how to do that
i wanted to be a clown
oh wow wow there's a helpline available
that was my i had no idea yours was that
big
you you feel foolish now don't you i
know
but listen we've got some unicycles here
we've got some unicycle then so you can
do this uh define can well
we'll see you can right yeah okay it's
in the visual pudding yes so if you come
over
to the unicycle okay can you really do
this
no don't do it there do it on the ground
don't go do it down here
yeah yeah yeah do over here shall i be
careful of that thing don't hit your
head
okay um no this is terrible um
i think i can like sort of do it are you
going to start to cry and tell us a
friend's been running
but um sort of like i i i kind of
in the play right i just need to come on
riding it i don't need to get on it on
the stage
would you help me get out yes yes all
right
everybody's a cheap gag cheers
this is going to be a disaster isn't it
okay
oh the sword of the lord is filled with
blood here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
one more one more one more oh god give
me strength man
i'll be honest i don't know i'll do it
myself okay so okay right
give me some room man
we've got another one we've got another
one we've got another one you can you
can both do it together here we go oh
look at yours
hey smart i'm gonna do together don't
crash into each other
you're sure meryl there is another one
i'd never wash it again okay here we go
yeah i'll follow you up no no you're
gonna go
[Applause]
not the trident yet we don't get to try
it until a little bit later next movie
so and i think the quindon did step back
there you this is this is the real
question
good reaction to a fork well done
well this one this one's a nice light
one oh i see i could do that
yeah aqua woman
i could make sushi quicker but do
can i do something with this yeah go on
don't hurt anybody listen
i i i do break a lot of these okay
i mean i do break a lot of them but
is this in one piece here we go still
one piece let's see if we can get around
oh yeah oh very good
oh my god
something that isn't part of official
merchandising which is
amazing uh somebody has baked a
christian gray cake
can you see the christian great cake
i've seen it online well it's right here
it this is it
so let's reveal the christian gray cake
look at that
look at that now
so this is this is this is a christian
gray cake from the thing
it's i know the lady who made it rose
where's rose
oh there you are there you are firstly
you must have a very tall oven
i'm sensing but how long did this take
um it took a team of
four of us about two to three weeks wow
come over and have a look at us come on
because i'm going to i'm going to give
you a taste in a bit
um no because we are allowed to eat it
uh because now tell us that these things
so that you it comes with it comes with
things
and these are all edible as well yes
these are licorice
yes they're gonna eat it they're real
they're actually quite nice can i have
something no do it's delicious
have some okay and actually let's look
and i've got a very very very
they kept toiling me afternoon graham
the knife is
very sharp like i'm just going to kill
all the guests
so uh thank you very much now rhode this
is
horrible but rosa said the best way to
cut into it is in the stomach
oh so sorry jamie
okay it's like a movie is this about
right am i doing it right
crack now she says no no back on she
said hang on
and then down here like that yeah
oh cause i've got cream in it
[Laughter]
actually can i just say i'm doing a very
good job i'm doing a very good job
wouldn't that make a lovely chest of
drawers
uh hang on i'll do a bit here here's the
good deeper
oh hang on there's a bit i can get a bit
here look at that that's lovely now that
is great
that's it well
i was doing very well now i'm just
tunneling
it how do you taste
um better than i imagined
can i ask you a question yes why did you
do
he was it for an international cake show
and we've made a red room
that's totally edible and we're taking
it to london so he is for a reason he
isn't just because i
like him he now has a rather unappealing
hole in his stomach uh look at that no
delicious and well on the cake very good
let's go and sit down let's look for
that
well uh emma for you
what is the hold that the spice girls
have over you
is this real yes it's real
and and i just feel like i've been
talking more about the spice girls on
this press tour than i have about the
movie
you went i did australia i know i wept
did you really
i really did but now which one was
talking to you melby
and was she really talking to her was it
a message no it was a video message on
an
ipad and that made you cry yes
were you jet lagged yeah but i also
you don't i mean i you do understand
because we're in the uk yeah i was
i was a fiend i was obsessed with the
spice girls
and they taught me about girl power and
i
love them i think they're fantastic
there's so many jamie there's so many
people
spice up your life every morning spice
up your lunch
hey there's so many and they're so
fantastic and today on the radio
um mel c talked to me over skype oh oh
so it's really very exciting okay who
would you say is your favorite spice
girl emma bunton baby spice
she's your favorite she's my favorite
who's next
cue that just a question all of the
other four
so emma bunsen well emma bunting was the
one that i had blonde hair and bangs and
my name obviously is
now emma my name was emily but it was
taken
when i became an actor um and so
now it's emma and uh yeah i just i
love so give me this so you one gave you
a video message and one talk to you on
skype yes
what are you telling me you've never met
are you going to are you going to do
something
have you never seen this are you going
to do something really have you never
met a spice girl um
wait hold on i have to mentally prepare
myself
have you never met a spice girl not in
the flesh
okay now as you know as you know
as you know emma it is very rare it is
very rare for more than one spice girl
to appear together
[Applause]
for any reason at all
[Music]
so they're not here
[Applause]
[Music]
you